hello folks
i'm speaking to you from the uh
rather small but very cozy fourth
bedroom of my my house at the moment
my reason of all the rubbish that's
going on in the world so talking about
functional programming in javascript
uh my contact details are there on the
screen at the moment feel free to grab
them if anyone's interested i'll try and
put this back up at the end i'm around
on social media and available if anyone
has any further questions slash abuse to
her let me
i'm a big fan of films so i don't so
much have a schedule as a program of
events and we are going with the
slightly inaccurately named 6ws who what
where when why and how of functional
programming
so first off who is it i'm going to
introduce three people significant to
the history of functional programming
one of these guys is a software
developer see if you can guess which as
we go around
but this first gentleman is alonzo
church
he i don't i don't have anyone who can
see my mac can focus in my mouse pointer
i'll take your silence as a yes
okay wonderful sorry don't know how
interactive we are this is the first of
these i've done
so uh this gentleman is significant for
a few reasons amongst them for us as
developers is this guy the arrow
function that's what this is it's an
arrow function this is mathematics
though this is from an old mass paper
from the 50s and the second is this guy
here this donates a parameter it's the
greek letter lambda and this is where we
get the term lambda expression
this is haskell curry who has something
like three programming languages named
after him
and we're interested in him for this
which i'll be getting to later this is
currying
don't worry about what that means at the
moment
now this guy might well be our software
developer
i can't imagine why we'd think that
um this is john mccarthy
he developed arguably the first uh pro
functional programming language in the
whole world lisp in the 1960s
so what is functional program not
the point of the last few slides was to
point out that it's not new there's
nothing new about functional programming
in fact i started digging into the maths
papers that formed the foundation of
functional programming and they date
back to the late 1800s
honestly i can't understand a single
thing written in any of them because i'm
not a mathematician i'm an engineer i
don't understand it frankly
but it isn't new at all it's not like
the latest version of angular react or
whatever it's not the latest framework
that's competing with the others it's
old
it's been around for a long time the
first programming language dates back to
the 60s and most of the heavy work dates
back actually to the 50s
it's not actually a language it's a
paradigm
a paradigm is a style of programming in
in a way
if we want the metaphor of a guitar then
we may take our guitar and we may play
many forms of music on it we can play
rock we can play
pop we can play country if you have no
soul
whatever but the point is that you can
take your language and do many things so
similarly with our programming language
we can do uh
we can do object orientated we can do
functional and an awful lot of languages
these days support all three
javascript particularly support
functional very well
and what is it also not it is not
imperative nor is it object orientated
most of the folks that i found that
struggle with understanding are the
folks that have been doing object
orientated for ten plus years and find
it hard to adopt to a slightly new style
of work
it's not the solution to all of our
problems although i would argue it's the
solution to many as hopefully i will
demonstrate over the coming 40 minutes
or so
it's also not difficult
and argue it's really not it means
dropping some preconceptions and
learning a slightly new way of looking
at a dev but it's not necessarily
difficult
so what actually is it
there's a whole load of concepts a lot
of these have got rather strange
complicated names although what they
actually mean generally isn't all that
hard to grasp
immutability
this just means that once you've set a
variable you can't change its state in
the javascript world pretty much just
means stick const on nearly everything
and stop using let
uh or
higher order functions this is something
that folks in the javascript community
have been doing for ages compared to
folks over in like.net and java this is
passing around functions as if they were
variables
either as parameters to a function as
the return from a function however but
that's all it is function functions
passed around as variables
it emphasizes functions not statements
now what does that mean
a statement is something like an if it's
a where it's a for
anything of that sort
generally speaking as a rule of thumb
and functional programming if there is a
question the answer is usually functions
more functions
and that holds surprisingly true for a
lot of situations
referential
transparency this means that
a function does not rely on anything
beyond its parameters
and the consequence of this is that it
becomes extremely predictable in its
behavior it means that given the same
parameters
it will always return the same answer no
matter what no matter the life of the
universe no matter the state of the
system well let us switch it off
no matter anything
so this makes it very very very testable
very predictable
recursion i'm hoping we're all good on
recursion if
we're not going to dwell on recursion
much in this talk but you know yeah it's
an important d pattern recognition we'll
come to that this is kinda like a case
statement with knobs on
stateless
there's no state object orientated tends
to rely on the paradigm of you've got
your state object you update it and you
keep touching the same state object we
don't generally do that in the
functional world there are reasons
uh amongst them it and
one of the great benefits it brings you
is that things like um
async become very easy to support
because you don't have a shared state
between functions there are other ways
now the monads
monads is the one that has a reputation
for being an awful pain in the bum to
understand
and certainly if you go looking on
wikipedia and some of these slightly
more mathsy sites you will see these
really horrid definitions of monad that
involve f of g is g of or whatever i
don't really know i don't understand i'm
not a mathematician
but according to douglas crockford the
curse of the monad is that once you gain
the ability to explain it you lose
it once you gain the ability to
understand the monad you lose the
ability to explain it so
not really necessarily planning to
and
it is not
difficult as i'm hoping i'll demonstrate
over the over this talk
so where is it where do we find it
there are of course the pure functional
languages ascor airline elm never used
them personally i know some folks that
swear by haskell erlang i think it has
got its uses all over i believe um
there are some cueing systems out there
that are written in airline rabbit mq i
think that's an airline
it's a poor functional programming with
each iteration of net that gets released
and it's working out pretty well and
they've even got a mostly functional
language f sharp which is an alternative
to c sharp vb whatever
and of course javascript
javascript definitely does support
functional very well
when is it
so when is it particularly good
it's good for data processing that is
given this data turn it into this data
that's the sort of thing functional does
really well that's very pure that's not
requiring much interaction
concurrent systems that is
where you want to stack a whole load of
instances of the same function side by
side
there's no shared state so concurrency
is very enabled by functional
high criticality because
functional programs in general tend to
be more robust than object orientated or
um
procedural code so if it's very
important your system go up and stay up
then functional might well be something
to consider
allegedly with stuff like airlang once
you've actually got it to compile
then nothing on this earth will ever
make it break now i don't know i've not
tried that but it seems entirely
plausible
and serverless if we're interested in
service mostly for the um the previous
three reasons that's again
functional is the sort of thing that
might easily enable you to get into
serverless
so where is it not now it's not that
functional can't do these things it's
just that these are some of the areas
where um
you have to make compromises
ui obviously because there is nothing
more impure than a human being they
they're about we're about as dirty and
impure as it gets to the computer world
now obviously javascript's often obvious
often meant to be
out on the front line with the user but
what we need to do generally is maximize
the pure area of functionality and then
minimize the amount of dirty human
interaction
uh external interactions with other
systems same sort of reason in
output interacting with files because
who knows that the file is there is not
there whatever this is all and high
performance
okay
i don't know why that oh yes high
performance systems because sometimes um
it depends this might not be the case
with javascript so much
uh with some systems with some
programming language certainly like c
sharp
making it more functional may not
necessarily be functionally the most
performant choice
but
this may not be the only concern you
have when developing your system
often we're more interested in
testability in sustainability
readability if you're more interested in
those things which in fairness i would
argue that most businesses are because
most businesses
are
keen that the development efforts get
done fast rather than anything else then
again functional is still probably what
you want
so why is it why why are we interested
it's concise
you can now normally i would gesture
wildly with my arms but you have to
imagine that at the moment
but
no you can compress
pages of code
down to just a couple of lines
potentially it's a lot more concise than
old fast and object-orientated
procedural code
it's more readable mostly because of the
conclusion that you've added in with uh
compacting the code right down and it
tends to enforce the um
writing the code in an order of
operations that's more logical and
consistent with what we're actually
trying to uh
we're trying to achieve very testable
mention that and concurrency i mentioned
that and robustness hey
and it's fun
i hope everyone will agree by the end
so this is an old-fashioned bit of
object-orientated procedural code
now
if i gave everyone five seconds to
understand what on earth this was doing
you'd probably struggle
and there's a good and that's because
our order of operations is all over the
place there's all sorts of bits of code
structure in there that are just there
to be structure it's it's a bit harder
to read
than say
something oh oh sorry um i'll go on to
that in a moment sorry slides for order
change there okay
but
in
functional we could just write this on
about a line or so so this is my test
case this is what i'm actually feeding
into the thing
so this is a test i what i'm actually
doing
is i'm taking a small little csv of the
titles of doctor who stories for those
unfamiliar doctor who is the greatest tv
series in the entire world
and this is the story titles from the
first series in 1963
along with my personal rating of those
stories so
what i actually want to get out of it is
pass this down to data structure and
then take out my favorite stories and
then give us back the titles which is
what this lot is actually doing in a
slightly convoluted way
and this is how we do it functionally
if anyone's thinking this is just an
awful lot of out of the box uh es6
functions then yep pretty much
that's what it is and
if you've been developing in this style
you've pretty much been doing functional
programming for a while now
and what how are we doing again the
order of operations is nice and simple
and laid out in a flow split on new line
then split each of those lines on comma
do a filter where i'm parsing
item 2 to it and then checking it to
before and then finally select out
just item one
easy
that's an awful lot more compact than
the first uh code sample
it's a lot easier to read and understand
what it's done it's a lot easier to
modify because we can easily just
throw an extra line into this uh
functional flow it's obvious where to
make a change and how
and that's what functional programming
is what we want to do in effect is put
the rest of our language into this
structure in order to continue
and i'll
demonstrate using uh
some well one of my favorite libraries
i'll juice at the moment and
i exp i did say that i would get into it
the concept of currying
so
in a normal non-curried function
we let's say an ad
we take it into oh that should be a var
i may possibly have reused these slides
from another language
don't tell anyone um we've got a var a
if our b and we're just saying it's
goes to a plus b so that's easy give it
10 20 we get a 30.
if this were a hypothetical
curried add and we gave it only the 10
does anybody out there want to hazard a
guess as to what we get out as the value
of answer to
well
the answer in fact is that you get back
a function because as often in
javascript in functional programming the
answer is a function or functions
so if you
give this curried ad simply one
parameter the 10
you get back a function which kind of
demonstrating here
which
has the one
firm value filled in and the second
still required and that is a parameter
to the function that's been returned so
by giving our add
a single parameter we've converted it
into an add 10 function
and
this
seems a bit strange but it is in fact
very very powerful
and then you can just give it the second
one the uh you can call this answer two
function
uh give it the second parameter and you
get back an answer finally
so the way to we could introduce this to
javascript is by one of my very favorite
libraries in the whole world this is
ramda js
i'm a huge fan of this guy
and
most of the rest of the talk is going to
be using ramda which i'm a big fan of
this
provides an awful lot of functions that
are very similar to things that like um
underscore or lowdash give you
but given a more a more distinctly
functional and
approach and using currying on
everything by default
so this is an example of a rounder
function this is one filling in all the
parameters
nth here so
ramdi uses it and
what do you call a namespace r generally
i mean when you're importing it you can
call it what you like of course but r is
as good as anything
um
so r.nth
says
give me this array and i will give you
the whatever is in the nth position nice
and simple so all it means is in the
warmth position whatever you're uh
you're getting that item so zero one
it's that one so we're saying
one is the position data is the data it
gives back a capital b because that is
there
so far so good
but what we can do
is we can only give it the one
we haven't given it the data at this
point
so what that means is that get array 1
here
is now a function
it's a function that given any array fed
into it it will give you whatever is in
position 1 in that array so now i have
to find two arrays data one and data two
and i'm forming an array here down here
which is a call to get array one here
with data one fed in and the data two so
i'm reusing the exact same code to fetch
the first item out of each
so we end up with an array at the end
which is a b and an f a b for this one
left for this one
and i've defined in one position what
the logic is for turning my array into
the data that i want
this is a ridiculously simple example
and we wouldn't necessarily do this in
the real world but it's just to
demonstrate the principle
and you can just
easily slide it into
my existing functional chain here r.nth
one here because
everything in
ramda unless you supply every single
parameter to the thing evaluates
generally to another function so this is
my arrow function simplified without the
arrow into a simple call to nth one
and what i'd like to do
is to try and pop the rest
of this structure into this same use the
same approach to compact it down and
hopefully
simplify further what we're actually
trying to do but first i need to
introduce another structure that i'll be
using
so i used to work for a us company
and being british
one of the things we would often do is
discuss the weather because this is no
joke what british people do a lot
so the american folks would say and i'm
not doing the accent because i can't and
it's embarrassing but they would say
something like it's 100 degrees outside
now i would think 100 degrees ooh that's
hot enough to boil water what the hell
but of course they mean 100 fahrenheit
uh the system used as far as when we're
only within the us
so the formula for converting from
fahrenheit to celsius is deduct 32
multiplied by 5 divided by 9
because of course it is why wouldn't it
be
but what we have
is a series of operations here and each
one is taking
a value operating on it storing that
somewhere and then the next line is
taking the previous step modifying it
further and so on step to step to step
like a relay race
now because of that we've got an awful
lot of
code noise here we've got all these
consts that actually we're never going
to use aside from just in this one
instance this a is unused here this b
only hit we've got the return and so on
here well strictly speaking all of this
we don't really need
we could use
um a perfectly nice structure in rambert
which i will be getting to
but first
ramda does have an add subtract multiply
divide it has all of these guys so we
can start throwing these into functional
trees as well
these of course are all carried so if we
simply wanted to add
or multiply then it's very easy to
create a quick
curried version of those if we do the
add and call our pass only a 10 to it
then we add 10 easy peasy we've got an
add 10 function similarly with the
multiply because the order of operations
doesn't matter with these guys
but
with the
subtract and the divide the order of
operations is important
when i say subtract 20 15 here this is
20 minus 15. it's actually in the order
that you would sort of say it when
you're describing uh describing a
mathematical operation divide somebody
is there 100 divided by five
so if we want to curry these guys we
probably want to actually
change the order of operations or to
curry
um a function other than
let's say provide other than the the
second one as our uh parameter to our
resulting carried function so
ramda has
a feature here called our it's an
underscore underscore that's actually
two underscores
this is a function that is a special
case what it's meaning is
with a subtract i am supplying all of
the parameters but i'm saying that the
one that the curry function that comes
out of it should actually supply this
parameter is the one i'm saying i'm
saying this is the whole this is the bit
that needs to be filled in by the next
call to the function we're generating
so by doing this i'm saying please now
get next person supply the first one and
then i'll give you the 15. so
that in fact means i've now created a oh
that's wrong that's wrong i've now
created a subtract 15 function
and down here again i'm telling the
thing that this is the one i want to be
supplied later so i've now just created
a divide by five function easy
so then finally we could put all of this
stuff into my new fahrenheit to celsius
converter using something called pipe
and pipe does exactly the process that
you saw on the old version of this code
it's
now bearing in mind of course as again
with almost everything around it this is
a function
so r.pipe is a function that takes a
single parameter which is whatever it is
that's been supplied in which hopefully
is a number uh she probably won't
actually do some uh validation of that
in the real world but i'm keeping things
a little simple here
so ardot pipe takes our single parameter
which will be our 100 degrees
and then it passes it to the first
function in the chain
which is a subtract
and we're filling in the blank here so
it's taking whatever that
parameter passed in is
filling it in there subtracting 32
whatever the result of that is pipe will
now push it in to this one to multiply
by five whatever the result of that is
will push into here and then we'll fill
that final value here and divide it by
nine this
in its very simplest form is a monad in
case anyone was interested
there's more to a monad than this but
this is the very simplest version of
that that concept
a relay race just
a series of operations each one passing
a value to the next after operating on
it until finally we collapse out to a
final value at the end
and returning to our our function here
this is our parser so if we wanted to
convert all of this into a rounded up
structure we can now use our pipe
yep there we go like that so pipe says
give me the value then i will do r.split
and again all of these are curried
functions these all generally take one
more parameter than you're seeing here
and that final parameter is almost
always the value the data on which to
operate
so
i am splitting on newline then i'm doing
a map and our.map is just the same as a
map as we're used to it and into that
i'm passing the function r.split so
split on newline split each line of that
on comma
then a filter which is
i'm filling it in long hand there i'm
actually creating an arrow
function to do that there's probably a
smarter way but
that's that looks good enough to me and
finally a mod r dot map where i'm
passing it r dot nth which is that means
go through the entire array and select
out the first item from it and
functionally this is exactly identical
to all the previous versions of the
parse you've seen
um you can run this through unit tests
you'll get the precise same result but
this is a bit more compact
and we're relying a lot more on
code that someone else has provided for
us
so
moving on to another sort of example of
the the uh sort of functional structures
we we would do
this is a
password validator it's a password
validator with a series of rules
but it's quite long it's got a lot of
repeated structure with these early
return falses
and we could compact this down a whole
load make this a bit easier to follow
because i've seen how out of hand these
things can get if you let them i've seen
functions of this sort that end up
growing
so much that they end up looking like
family trees and the functional
structure will tend to restrict people
in terms of how much of that sort of uh
uh
craziness they try so we've got our
rules we must not be
it must not be undefined and then
convert to a string and then we're
saying it must be
uh
less than or equal to two it must be
greater than ten it must not be justin
bieber because it must not
so that first bit is e that last bit
sorry is easy
a function in random to determine
whether something equals justin bieber
is easy that's just r dot equals so this
again is a carried function so whatever
you pass into is evil now it will
evaluate it against this and to tell you
whether or not it's uh it's the same
this is what we've actually generated
behind the scenes
but if we want to find out if it is not
that if we want to
reverse the the logic of that stat
function then r.complement is what we
would use
so our complement
takes um a function that returns boolean
and then it returns you back a another
function but one which does the opposite
of that so this r dot equals checks
whether we are equal to justin bieber
the r complement of that
checks that we are not equal so it is
not
x is triple equal to justin bieber
easy
and
if we wanted to assert against
properties
well that's not too difficult either
this prop eek does exactly that it says
that
this
gets back a function which asserts that
the property b
is equal to capital b
so if we were to feed this function
this object would get back a true
because it does have a b and a b so
that's fine
but the property that we want to assert
against is length
and we don't want to say that it's equal
to something we want to say that
it's within a range
now there is actually another function
for doing this in rambler and that's
prop satisfies
and what prop satisfies requires is
wouldn't you know it a function
uh which
is the function
that's the predicate that we're saying
has to be met in order for this prop
satisfies to return true so we're saying
that whatever this property is it has to
be greater than two here we're saying
that the property we're asserting
against is length so this now has
returned a function which will check the
length of any given
uh object you pass to it and assert that
its length is greater than two
and we can go a step further and just
use r dot gt greater than and pass it to
and we've got back exactly the same
thing
so this then
is
the new version of my password rules
so i'm using a structure here called
r dot or
now all would be they're certainly very
familiar to me from my c sharp days
and what all means is
i am going to give
a whole list of functions
and i'm going to evaluate them one after
the other
and
given that any of them return false
then i will terminate the soul thing
early and return out
false and in this case what we're doing
is this again is a single parameter
function this whole thing validate
password is a function
which takes a single parameter which is
our data which will be hopefully our
password
one second
sorry um
so and it's passing that same value
one after the other into each of these
functions i have generated
so the first is actually an r dot is nil
and this is our uh catch all check
against whether the the value the
variable is defined or not and i'm doing
the r dot complement of it
so this effectively means first check
that this thing is undefined or whatever
and this thing means do the inverse so
what i'm saying is that um
i'm actually saying that all of these
things have to be true in order to be
validated so this is in effect
it's not nil it's not undefined it's not
whatever
r dot is is so flipping useful that i
would use it all over the place and this
is
pass in the type as it were that you
wish to check it to be and it'll tell
you whether that's true or not so i'm
saying r is string
so
we've passed in our password we're
checking that it's not undefined now
we're checking that it's a string so
the rest of the predicates can continue
um safely on the assumption that this is
a string because otherwise once we start
checking against length it could be an
array or who knows what
so prop satisfied i'm saying greater
than two
and prop satisfied less than or equal to
ten
so that's our lengths satisfied and also
that it is not just in bieber because it
must not be
so all of that
gives us our set of password rules but
again written in a fairly nice fairly
easy to read way
it's very easy to understand how exactly
to modify if if i were ever to throw in
a new rule it would literally just be an
extra one line in this structure or
maybe a modification
and
it's
i would argue it's a lot easier to work
with i mean there is a little bit of the
overhead of this r dot business but once
you pass that the rest of it's quite
easy to work with
so
another example requiring us to do some
slightly different work and this is
something that probably an awful lot of
us in the programming biz will be
familiar with and that's fizzbuzz
for those unfamiliar and i'm i'm not
thinking there's going to be many of you
uh this is a very simple game where we
write out numbers
if one of them is divisible by three we
add fizz if it's divisible by five we
add buzz if it's divisible by both like
15 we add fizz buzz
i don't know why but this this is the
go-to um coding exercise i often get set
in interviews but fine
so
how do we do this using our functional
rounder code well first off we'll need a
map of course
and i will get on to exactly what the
implementation of this cat this is this
is the thing that says given a number
here's the output that i'm going to give
you either a number or a string
i'll get into that in a second but first
we're generating a range
now the range is saying generate me an
array
between
length whatever between which has values
in it between one and whatever num is
whatever the um
whatever the highest number that you
want in my previous example it's 20.
so this is generating us an array of
integers between 1 and 20 and then using
map we're feeding each and every one of
those into
this function here
so another structure to introduce that's
the if else
we'll be using that in just a moment
and this is a handy little
kind of like logical switch statement
and this again is a function and takes a
single parameter like everything else
and it's saying first off
whatever the parameter is pass it into
the first item in the structure that's
the in my case it's r equals
five so what it's saying is whatever has
been passed into this function here
pass it here and this will tell me
whether or not it equals five
if it does equal five
then
pass it into this function and do the
transformation now always means
that's what it always returns so
always means disregard the parameter and
just return this
so if it is five we get back f i v e 5
as a string
otherwise pass the parameter into this
one identity
now identity actually also means
disregard the parameter well no it
doesn't what it means is take the
parameter
and just return it completely unmodified
so a little if else structure here is
saying
take a parameter check whether it's five
if it's five return back the text to
five otherwise if it was three let's say
then return that back that three exactly
as it was without touching it
so
moving on we've got
um
we've got a pipe here
and the pipe is using the if else
so
this is a pipe so it's passing the
parameter this this is
the thing that's called by the map in
our previous line of code
so that means that this is operating on
each item in this range array between 1
and 20. so the parameter to these is an
integer between 1 and 20. it's operating
on each one individually one after the
other
and it's checking them against these
rules
it's saying first
is it divisible by three i'll get on to
that in a moment
and if it is do i doubt concatenate i'm
putting the hole here to say
my original item goes here and then we
append
fizz
otherwise if it is not divisible by 3
then our identity that means return the
original value back unmodified
similarly here
if it's divisible by five
then we concatenate buzz
so that's a pipe
and we are either a concatenating a
three we're concatenating sorry a fizz
or a buzz or if neither of those
divisibles were true then we're simply
returning identity and unmodified value
so that's all of our logic for doing our
fizzbuzz pretty much in that one
statement
the indeed is divisible by by the way
looks a bit like this
and that's a pipe where we pass it math
mod is our modulus behaving in a
mathematical way which apparently the
the percentage in javascript doesn't
always we're saying
pop the value there
num is three or five as appropriate and
then we're saying
return back whatever this was passed
into equals compared here to zero so
there we go that's the divisible by
one of the last of my examples so this
is a card game that was introduced to me
as pontoon
but apparently in the us it's known as
blackjack
uh i've also heard it called 21 and a
few other names but the basic idea is
that you're taking cards one after the
other from the dealer
if it's a number card it's equal to that
number if it's a jack or queen or a king
the value of that is 10
the ace actually is equal to either one
or 11 i've simplified a little because
i don't want to get bogged down too much
so i'm saying the ace is 11. and the
idea is that you're taking cards to get
as close to 21 as you can but if you go
over 21 then you've lost
it it amused me as a kid
and if you wanted to do old-school
school you'd do something like this
if statements stuff all over the place
um but all we're doing is the scoring at
the moment
is because frankly it's too useful not
to
so
there is an r dot contains because i
don't want to do big long strings of ifs
looking at queen looking at king so on
when the answer is all the same i just
want to do one i want to compact that
down a bit further the problem with our
dot contains is it works in a slightly
interesting way for what i'm used to uh
and that is that first you say the thing
that should be contained in the array
then you pass the array which is the
other way around to what i'd kind of was
kind of like i would like the array and
then i would like to pass in the thing
to check it contains so
all of that just means that we need to
uh use another r dot underscore
underscore to fill in the to tell it to
fill in the blank here
but this is using another functional
structure called which round is called
khand khan for condition
and each parameter to this
this whole thing is an array and each
item in the array is itself an array a
two-part array the left-hand side of
each of these is a predicate that is
something that takes the parameter
evaluates it and then returns a true or
a false
this true or false is does this rule
apply
so
r dot is a number means if whatever the
per the parameter is is a number
then simply return it unmodified
moving on to the next line
we've got a slightly more complicated
condition and that's a contains and i'm
saying
our blank is here so we're filling in
here and i'm saying look in this array
if our value is contained within this
array return 10 so it's an odd always
10.
otherwise if it's an ace
and i don't always for 11. so
this structure this is pattern
recognition this is what it is we're
it's kind of like a switch statement but
with full-on um
functional expressions on the left-hand
side rather than simply um
checking against value and then on the
right-hand side again we've got a
full-on
function of some kind
this sort of structure is extremely
powerful and can enable you to write an
awful lot of code that would otherwise
be complicated and long-winded
and then moving on to
so if you want to imagine the sort of
basic functional flow
we start with an item let's call it
string generally speaking the first
option
chance you get you split it into an
array of strings or string or whatever
maybe you do a wear or something or a
filter rather to reduce the number a
select or a map rather to convert to
something else then finally
aggregate into a single value again
that's the sort of standard flow that
we'll run through when we're doing a
functional process but this aggregation
is the last step in the process that i
haven't really touched on so far
there are some built-in simple
aggregators some will do exactly what
you think passages right you get back
the sum
mean takes you an average
easy
but we want to do something slightly
more complicated
we want to take an array of cards in our
hand so in my imaginary example i've got
a one of five in a k so that's one five
and a king king's worth ten so that's
sixteen
and i want to
convert all of this into a single value
the score and that's where r.reduce
comes in
so audit reduce takes a function with
two parameters the accumulator and the
value so the accumulator
is the running total so far
and the value is the current item out of
the array
it also need to pass it um the starting
value which when we're calculating our
scoring cards is is going to be zero
so
when we run this the first time the
accumulator will be zero because that's
here
the value will be the first item out of
our array which is a one
and so we're saying that the new running
total is accumulated that is the old
running total
add the score of the card which is over
here that's this function that we
created this uh this pattern recognition
structure
so
one will go into scorecard it'll
actually match there is a number come
back as identity so the new running
total is one so then we'll call this
function again
and the new accumulator is one the new
value is now five
and we're saying that that is equal to
the old value that is one plus the score
now again it will be five so that means
that the new accumulator is six
calling this again we've got six here
and we've got k here
so when that goes into our scorecard
this will not match so we won't do
identity
this one will though and it will match
on king
so that means we'll bring back a 10 so
finally we'll get back our 16.
took me an awful long time to explain
that
but didn't take me very long to write it
and once you're used to working with
this pattern it's not really all that
difficult to throw these together
and if we want to go another step
further more complicated
um
we could do a pipe which is first which
then first does i reduce which is
reducing our array down from
this list of
cards to a value and then do it if else
to say
if it's less than or equal to 21
we'll do identity so that's your actual
score otherwise we'll do an always with
bust so in my examination example if we
pass in the one the five and the king
will again back a 16
otherwise
if we have a queen in there too
now the queen will take 16 to 26 and
that means that we will switch to being
bust
again
awful long time to explain not much time
to read or to understand
so this is the last bit and then you can
all relax
so i've got a hypothetical db get of
some description i don't really know
what it's doing i don't really care and
it's getting a record based on an id and
inside this is a data object of some
kind it's i'm imagining it's user data
or something of that sort
and i want to say hello to whomever i've
details i've just fetched possibly the
devil
and
i will call first name on that and put
it into a string now that's fine
provided that this actually works
that we actually do have
a record coming out of this and this is
not just undefined because otherwise
this is going to explode
so there is a structure in functional
programming that will allow us to do
this sort of thing without having to
sort in an awful lot of checks against
undefined all over the place
muddying up the code and getting in the
way of understanding what's going on
this is one way of implementing it i've
seen it done all sorts of other ways
but typically
it's called maybe
and maybe
is an object that just contains a value
uh think of it as a thing of the box so
we've got our value we're popping it
inside the box maybe is the name of the
box
and we've got two functions hanging off
its prototype the first is the get
valley which is just take the thing out
of the box and hand it over
and the second is bind
and bind takes a function
and what we do is
we check whether this this value is
actually defined or not
if it's not defined we will not execute
the function
we'll just return another maybe with
undefined contained within it otherwise
we'll return a new maybe and this time
we will execute funk whatever this is
with the value from inside our box
popped into that
and that's what it would actually look
like when you run it
so i'm saying my message is a new maybe
and i'm starting with my id and i'm
using bind and passing it in
a db get record so x here is a 666 and
that's going into there and that's
executing
now if this worked
this means that this would actually this
first bind would return a new maybe with
whatever the result of that is popped
into it and then the new maybe would
have a bind on it and this would be the
result of that
and then we could safely operate
knowing that this is defined
it might not be a terrible idea to
possibly put a try catch around it again
just in case first name doesn't really
exist and then finally you call that
value at the end to get the value out of
it
but if on the other hand
this returned nothing
then
this type of this value would be true
that would be undefined and we're simply
going to return our new maybe so that
means if db get record return nothing
this bind will not run this function
here this function will never be run
but um an undefined will be returned so
the value at the end will be undefined
and we can do something like at r.cond
or whatever to decide what to do with it
but the point is that
i've written my uh my flow of operations
in this single chain
and i don't need to start adding in lots
of code to check against uh whether the
previous operation worked or not i can
add in as many extra lines as i like and
all of these can assume that the
previous step succeeded because
otherwise the step will not be executed
and this is what a monad really is this
is the sort of thing that we really do
with them
there's a whole load of other monads
covering all sorts of other
other eventualities uh you could have
monads which
return
different objects depending on whether
previous steps worked or not you could
have monads that switched to containing
error messages and the result that an
error occurred
in fact if you've been messing with
promises those are a monad as well
so you may have been using some of these
longer than you expected
so i've got about 10 minutes left which
is not bad timing at all
does anybody have any questions at this
point
thanks a lot simon i i am in charge of
the questionnaire
site
uh there are questions for you oh well
yeah
it's not scary
how many of them contain abuse
none of them continue
all of those have been filtered away
already
the first question is for someone who
knows programming c and java what do you
think is would be the best functional
programming language any books you can
recommend
uh for c and e well okay uh i'm i
haven't done c since i was at university
and that's longer ago than i really care
to admit
um
java though i again don't know java but
i do know c sharp so
c sharp is actually a really good one at
the moment for getting into
functional programming because as i said
uh right at the beginning
uh microsoft now have a policy of
introducing more functional abilities to
their language as they go along they
things like the the pattern recognition
it's not entirely as um excuse me uh as
powerful as the structure i showed you
there but he's getting there and i
believe it's something they're
continuing to work on uh so i would
actually recommend a book called i think
it's functional programming in c sharp
by uh enrico bonanno
it's published by manning
and it's honestly one of the best
programming books i've read in a very
long time i absolutely adored that book
and it's examples of how you can start
doing functional programming in c sharp
today
using no extra libraries
and it explains things like the monad
and the pattern recognition system so
nicely that it's it's easy to work with
and the best thing you can do is don't
just read it grab out visual studio or
whatever and and do it
because a lot of the difficulty in
understanding functional programming
often comes from the concepts and
getting your head around it
and if you sit there and do it
i almost guarantee that would after some
time there'll be a light bulb moment and
suddenly it'll all become just obvious
and certainly for me now i get a little
annoyed if i have to write everything
out long hand
as it were you know doing it the old way
rather than doing it the nice quick easy
functional way so that's that's my
personal favorite book um there is
functional programming in javascript by
the same publishers i haven't read that
in a great deal of detail it looked
quite good but it wasn't entirely what i
was after personally
um
it uses underscore so
if you use familiar with underscore you
might find that one useful um but
personally ramda is is one of my
all-time favorite libraries for almost
any programming language ever so also
i'd recommend checking out the ramda
website they have extensive
documentation on how their library works
yeah nice
uh we'll make sure that we'll get the
links for the books and we can publish
them together with the slides later on
okay i'll tell you what i haven't got my
god i put my camera on uh so that you
nice people there we go hello
you're currently not visible though
they can only see the questions i can
put you on
oh
there are two more questions though uh
i'm already i'm already married i'm
sorry
i uh
uh what what do you think of
observablehq.com if you've heard of it
i have not i am really sorry and i'm
literally writing down that right now
because i'm i'm so sorry but i've never
heard of it
all right
uh one last question uh
which goes more on the broad side i
guess what do you think about rust
again not heard of that one
all right apologies to everybody that's
a programming language i think isn't it
so
i do not like that in my car
i have i don't know anything about it as
a programming language so again
apologies uh javascript and c-sharp are
predominantly all i ever work in
all right
that's all the questions we had uh
thanks a lot for the talk for me as a
haskell evangelist ever since i first
saw it
it's it's great to see that functional
programming is catching on everywhere
nowadays so
yeah if in fact i was having a chat with
the summer intern when i was in the us i
was having a chat with like their summer
interns and they were saying that
uh in their universities now
functional is the sort of programming
that they're teaching them
so
i do get the and certainly when i go to
things like ndc oslo and things like
that um
i get the impression there is more
functional content
each year compared to the previous and
people are starting to name check at
least functional even in the
non-functional talk so it is definitely
a very coming thing and something that's
becoming extremely uh
increasingly important as the years go
on
yep it's nice and thanks again for a
great talk